au point qu'un homme star la musique
populaire coréenne a conquis le monde
avec cette chanson
le vidéoclip de gangnam star sortie en
2012 est et visionner trois milliards de
fois sur youtube
mais pour alexandre à san diego la
passion pour la pop coréenne lac et pop
a débuté bien avant
la jeune femme née en alberta dont les
parents ont émigré des philippines
l'amour de tous qui est coréen est né
ici quand elle avait 11 ans tout n'y est
pas waze est pour moi la kpop c'était un
moyen d'échapper à mon quotidien
edmonton d'aller ailleurs
et puis ces chanteurs ils ont l'air plus
propre plus conservateur que les
chanteurs de rap ça me ressemblait dès
l'adolescence elle commença à prendre
ses premiers mots en coréen avant de
prendre des cours à l'université
je voulais comprendre ce qu'il disait
mais mieux à monza here and roll aussi
est une fan de culture coréenne des
films surtout quand elle aura terminé
son bac à l'université de l'alberta elle
veut déménager à séoul pour devenir
actrice
là bas il ya beaucoup de réunions où
beaucoup de drames et il ya aussi pas
vraiment beaucoup de personnes qui
parlent anglais n'ont plus franc fait
donc selon elle le coréen est plus
facile que le chinois parce qu'il n'ya
pas des milliers de caractères à
apprendre
juste un alphabet avec les différences
l'aps former des mots jusqu'à moroni au
matériau robben partout au pays
plus en plus d'étudiants après le coréen
à l'université de l'alberta le nombre
d'inscrits est passé de 50 à 5 150 en
dix ans à l'université de montréal on
compte trois fois plus d'étudiants qu'il
y a 4 ans et à l'université de toronto
150 personnes sont sur une liste
d'attenté
une action plus intéressés par la
culture mais y en a d'autres qui va le
faire du business en corée et au japon
la corée du sud et ailleurs le septième
partenaire économique du canada
et selon plusieurs experts si le coréen
y populaire aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
grâce aux médias sociaux et jeunes
occidentaux ont accès à de la musique
des films qu'ils n'auraient pas pu
consommer il ya 20 ans le gouvernement
coréen fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
promouvoir sa culture à l'étranger
alexandra par exemple a pu chanter en
direct de chez elle dans une émission de
télé coréenne le coréen a donc beau être
exotique
il est accessible et comment est ce
qu'on vit merci encore et un merci fait
comme femme n'est pas comme ça hamida
oui je combats ici l'heure incertain
radio canada ént